I feel like a part of growing up is
experimenting with different things like
some girls experiment with girls some
girls experiment can't get that way so
like what so you're saying sexual
experience you just have one partner
that you want to have a kid with and get
married to and that's it you one you
really don't have you only had sex with
one person that you want to marry that's
[__] [__] no obviously notan the
[__] then that's what you
like but you should only have sex with
someone you're willing to have a child
what's the problem with having
there nothing
with sayyar old girls that you should
have one partner I didn't say that I
said you should have sex with someone
you're willing to have a child with